all right he's kicking into the enclosed
end of Coliseum ty Montgomery that his
goal line montgomery retreats inside its
goal and he's gonna do the rams a favor
and bring it out to the 10 to 15 and he
tackled at the 20 boil we got the ball
out ball is out the Rams take over
[Applause]
Aaron Rodgers never got a chance with
the football we can all feel it coming
last year week eight Chris we were in
the studio at NBC watching that game and
there was a sense that here's Aaron
Rodgers he's gonna do it again ty
Montgomery defying orders to stay in the
end zone brings the ball out and Aaron
Rodgers doesn't get the opportunity to
drive the ball down the field and win
the game with a field goal or a
touchdown so what if Wednesday
what if Montgomery follows orders and
let's follow it to its logical
conclusion that Rodgers would have done
what everyone thought he was gonna do
helped the Packers win the game what
does that mean from the Packers
perspective who were three two and one
at the time they had just won on a
Monday night against the 49ers after
coming from behind does it change things
last year for the Packers does it keep
Mike McCarthy ultimately employed well I
mean this is a fun exercise okay I do I
do like this I mean you know it's it's
the offseason and we could play around
with things like this I do think the
Green Bay Packers the last 3-4 years
there's not been a team that's been more
hungry or fed or off of momentum more
than the Green Bay Packers and
especially the momentum that one guy has
supplied for them and that's Aaron
Rodgers I mean Aaron Rodgers we've seen
it over the last five or six years he's
made Packer teams who I'm not sure we're
playoff quality teams believe that they
were Super Bowl teams because they go
damn we got number 12 we got a chance
and same with the public in the media
you know I mean little out of years so
hey listen I look at this and I got a
headphone with this oh gosh okay Aaron
Rodgers gets the ball there ty
Montgomery doesn't fumble they're gonna
go down they're gonna win that football
game he had the Mojo going right then
right there the next week I think now
the team is feeling good about
themselves okay we're hot they're going
to New England we saw in that game Aaron
Jones fumbled late when Aaron Rodgers
was also getting hot in that game and
about to take over it certainly seemed
he was kind of in that mode once again
but now with Ty Montgomery not issue not
happening I could I think the Packers
going to run I really do I look at it as
going beating the Rams they pull magic
off against the New England Patriots
they beat the Miami Dolphins now because
they're hot they're going to Seattle I
don't think Mike McCarthy punts the ball
on fourth and one he
that's Aaron Rodgers throw it they get
the first down they win that game okay
I'll say they lose at Minnesota they
beat the Cardinals instead of losing
that horrible game they beat the Falcons
they lose to the Bears beat the Jets
beat the Lions end up in the playoffs as
the number five seat at 11 four and one
but what happens is the rams end up the
number three seed now the Bears of the
two seed the Seahawks of the six seed
the Eagles aren't in the playoffs and
Aaron Rodgers beats the Dallas Cowboys
in the divisional round okay and the
Seahawks upset the Rams in the wild-card
game because it's the third time they
played Seahawks go play in the New
Orleans Saints New Orleans Saints win
Rams I mean excuse me Packers therefore
go ahead and play I want to make sure I
got this right now you brought this all
down the Chicago Bears now they win that
game okay and now we got Aaron Rodgers
Jew Breeze in the NFC Championship game
and you know what happens there because
the Packers are hot they get blown out
by New Orleans at home in New Orleans
just like they did it against Atlanta a
few years back and Mike McCarthy still
gets fired so nothing changed I think
we're still back at square one can I add
a grievance please in my prior list yeah
everything you just said now just look
hey yeah yeah I'm just messing with you
the one of those things you glossed over
the Rams if they end up the three seed
the Seahawks would have been the same I
remember what I always say my but I was
saying I just said I'm just saying I
like that well you were covering a lot
of ground there yeah I say your stick
you still got the endorphins flowing
from your passionate defense of our plan
and I don't mean that sarcastically I
thought we were gonna have more likely
to do this so when I heard them say a
minute I was like oh my gosh but yeah I
had the Seahawks beat in the Rams I
thought about you there and then you
know yeah I tried to do the ripple
effects but I don't know I hope
everybody enjoyed mine is I think your
instincts are right right that the
Packers are one of these teams that just
they had this propensity to shoot
themselves in the foot and if they
hadn't done that maybe they'd have more
than one Superbowl championship over the
past day
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports